I'm going to start with updates let's
talk about Kieran where is Kieran now
and how is she doing Kieran is in a much
better space she's now almost uh 20
she's going to be 20 um next next year
early next year uh and she is a young
woman looking for her place in the world
you are making this film not knowing
whether or not Kieran is going to appear
on camera so you're making the entire
movie unsure of how that's going to play
out what were the conversations that you
had with Karen and her family and then
then with the larger community of people
who work with survivors of sexual
assault about what was right and what
you felt you needed to discuss and
consider before you made a decision the
the film that I ended up making was not
the film that I had set out to make and
the film that I had set out to make was
a film that was focusing on the work of
the NGO they were working with men and
boys they started a gender sensitization
program across the state of jant so the
focus of of my film was really that that
program and uh and and the way I came
across the story was because renit was
was somebody that was enrolled in that
program as were the rapists actually the
focus for me for the longest time was
masculinity and and initially I was
going to actually weave this story and
two other stories together you know and
I felt that this this film would be the
spine of a larger piece a larger piece
on masculinity it was only once I got
into the edit room and we've been been
editing for about 2 and a half years
that we realized you know we really had
two separate films in the material and
this particular story just needed its
own filmic Universe it was demanding it
was demanding that um and that's when
you know the the idea of how to uh you
know how to honor her Humanity how to
find a way to obviously not reveal her
while at the same time not oblit ating
her Humanity or NE negating her Humanity
uh so that was a that was a long process
and it took a couple of years and we
tried many many different things
everything felt ethically wronged you
know I mean like blurring her face out
or using you know somebody else's Voice
or whatever the workarounds would be
yeah yeah we we literally actually we
did a number of things so we we you know
we did this very beautiful creative blur
we tried animation we literally did give
her a a new face like with with using uh
the face of an actor um and everything
felt wrong you know and but it was
obviously it was you know it was it was
we had to do what we had to do and
because it took so long for us to make
the film she'd become an
adult and so we started bringing up this
idea you know and her her parents were
very proud of her and they didn't want
her to to be hidden uh but it was clear
to them and it was clear to us that if
if she was going to come forward it was
going to have to be her choice so we
showed her the fine cut of the film and
as soon as she saw it she she agreed and
and when I asked her why she chose to
come forward why she wanted to why she
wanted to do this was really emotional
and and she said that for her she
herself couldn't believe her courage as
a 13-year-old child when she saw the
film she was in awe of her 13-year-old
self and she felt that that 13-year-old
self needed to be celebrated you know
something else happens in the making of
the this film and that is that you and
your
crew become targets of what feels like a
potentially dangerous situation and it's
proof of how seriously the village is
taking this story and your work
documenting this story but it also
changes the story itself because now you
are part of the story I realized fairly
early on that we were having an impact
and you know we all know that there is
no such thing as as absolutely kind of
objective uh Verity truth because you
know the truth is is as soon as you turn
a camera on on something you're
impacting reality you're having an
effect what I realized over the course
of making this particular film is this
there's a sort of triangle you know like
there's there's the there's the story
that we're capturing uh there there's
the the capturer and then there's the
viewer and we're all involved in this
kind of ethical triangle right and I
felt that by including it it was sort of
forcing us as consumers of images to
understand that what we
were you know that we were that the um
uh the capturing of images also there's
an ethical there's an ethical
consideration you know does everybody in
the film know what the stakes are
because the fact that um mud halik
allows you the access he does is
remarkable given what he says or does he
not even think that what he says is that
bad for him to say what he's
saying it's it's who he is it's what he
believes you know just as I believe what
I believe because I was raised in a
particular environment in a particular
time and place just as you believe what
you believe and and everyone else here
does as well you know he is just
speaking who he is and that's that's why
people are unguarded for me it was very
very important to give him a clear Arc
because I found him to be actually a
very complex human being um and you know
so at the end when he when he says uh
they did wrong and they deserve to be
punished but they're all children from
my Village you know that is where you
understand him that's where you
understand him even if you disagree with
him that's where you understand him he
sees everybody as a child AB absolutely
and and the other thing about him that's
so extraordinary so I was terrified to
show him the film I was so afraid to
show him the film but I showed him the
film and I was surrounded by a number of
male activists um as well we you know we
all we decided to show him the film
together uh and we were kind of nervous
but he loved the film he absolutely
loved the film and he said that he was
after watching the film he was ashamed
of himself that's amazing and he felt
that everyone in the community needed to
see the film in order to see what they
had put this family through I want to
ask you about her parents without
knowing much about their education or
their
background they seem very astute her mom
says if we don't stand up for ourselves
they'll always try to push us around I
mean she could be mimicking civil rights
speakers how did they get to be those
people were they born with those beliefs
were their own parents people who made
sure that they understood that because
it certainly runs contrary to the
thinking in the village yeah I get ask
that question a lot actually you know
and and I always uh and I always think
what it is really is that that's how
change happens there's always one person
right this is this is how we make change
there's always this one human being that
decides that they're going to stand up
and and in this film it was Ranjit for
us what became very clear as we were
filming in is is that the drama actually
was playing itself out on rit's face his
face just spoke volumes and that's where
you know that's where the story was you
know so it was just really just allowing
him to be um you know allowing it to be
his his his journey we obviously have
molik saying I regret what I did but is
there a change in thinking that's
incremental in how men and boys are
starting to think about their behavior
yeah I mean without without a doubt
absolutely I mean you know mahinder
himself who's an extraordinary human
being and such a feminist and so evolved
was mutalik 10 years ago you know or 20
years ago rather right I mean he comes
from that so absolutely you know the the
change is the change is possible the the
program that they were running I mean
what they what they did was they were
actually creating Leaders with in the
communities them themselves right so um
uh you know so they they would they
would take these men and really work
with them for a number of years very
very extensively and the point is to the
work that they were trying to do was
actually to show that masculinity and
that
patriarchy is oppressive for men right
right it's not just it's not just about
you know the abuse of women right or the
violence against women it's actually
it's as you were we were talking about
earlier right this idea of constructs
and and um and the fact that constructs
you know by their very nature they
impose definition on you you know they
they constrict you they they actually
prevent you from understanding your true
self and your real humanity and that was
the point you know that was the point of
that program and of course you're not
going to change people in three or four
months right it's going to take it's
going to take years I'm want to ask you
this last last question and that's about
how you photograph Kieran in the last
quarter of the film she is radiant and I
don't know if it's something that you do
with lights or your cameras or is it
just her because we see her at the
beginning of the film in a shell and we
see her at the end come alive I it was
so powerful you know that moment where
she's um where she's getting ready in
front of the mirror and she's putting on
her Bindy you know and she's getting
ready for her testimony it's so it was
so beautiful it was just so powerful you
know and it's when she walks inside that
courtroom and she kind of is hanging her
head high you know and she comes out and
that and she when I I think my one of my
favorite lines is is uh when she says um
I'm gonna go eat mangoes you know so and
I think it's true documentary and
narrative filmmakers sometimes they
choose great stories sometimes great
stories Choose You and I think what
Kieran gave you as a filmmaker and the
way you responded to her offering is
remarkable so I want to thank Kieran who
is not here um but I also want to thank
Nisha for making this film thank you so
much for making a movie and sharing it
with us thank you thank
you